Hello, this is Ann from Connors Clinic and today's genetic video is going to be on the APOE gene.
This gene is also most well known as the gene to assess risk for Alzheimer's disease.
So really the APOE gene is a gene that essentially is kind of like a bucket that is carrying fats
and delivering them to different parts of the body where fats are needed in order to keep those parts of the body healthy.
So transportation of lipids is the role of the APOE gene.
And again, these fats are protective for the brain and protective for arteries.
So these healthy fats help to ensure your neurons remain healthy.
They are important for proper function of the synapses.
So those are the spaces between the neurons that are kind of carrying the signal from one neuron to the other.
So that synapse space lot is going on there and so these fats help to ensure proper function in that space.
They also are important for the integrity of the cell membrane.
So the membrane of your cells is made up of a phospholipid bilayer.
So you need fats, healthy fats in order to maintain the integrity of the membrane.
And then also these fats are important for the reduction of the plaque within the brain and in the arteries.
So of course that plaque build up within the brain is what contributes to Alzheimer's disease and plaque within the arteries contributes to coronary artery disease.
So those are things that we don't want.
So these fats are really important to help maintain balance within these areas and help maintain proper function and ensure that we have healthy brain and healthy arteries.
So with genetics and the APOE gene variance, there is a combination of three different alleles.
So we either have APOE2, APOE3 or APOE4.
And you inherit one allele from each parent.
The APOE2 allele is not very common and is associated with decreased risk of Alzheimer's disease, also decreased risk of coronary artery disease.
APOE3 is kind of the normal or baseline status.
So it doesn't increase or decrease risk of either.
And APOE4 is really the risk or the gene, the status that is most commonly associated with Alzheimer's disease and increased risk of artery disease.
So this is the one that you don't want found in about 15% of the population increases the risk again of Alzheimer's disease and about 40% of people with Alzheimer's disease carry this allele, the risk allele, APOE4.
So this really says that it is a contributor to Alzheimer's disease risk, but it is not the BL and all.
So your environment, your lifestyle choices, there are things that you can do to decrease risk even if you have the APOE4 status.
So know that this gene, and if you have the variant here, it is not, you know, it's not your destiny to get Alzheimer's disease or have coronary artery disease.
You're just at an increased risk, so knowing this information is really valuable because you can do things to then reduce your risk.
And on your genetic report, this is what this looks like. So the APOE gene is really in the first section, the gut health section because, again, it's associated with fats and lipid transfer.
So it's in the gut health section, kind of within that fats, proteins, and carbs section of your genetic report.
And you have two different versions of the APOE gene listed here, and then the variants column.
So depending on the variants that you have, it makes up your genotype.
And then you can follow the information over to the left hand side of your report to see what your APOE status is.
So the first identifying APOE gene here, this is this number, that is the unique identifying number, and it's listed here.
So that's the column here, and the second one is listed in the second column. So depending on your genotype, for each of these, you can follow this over and determine your APOE status.
So for this person here, who has no variants on either of these genes, they have a TTCC makeup.
So you can see TT over here, and then CC. So this is the normal expression. So this person has APOE 3 status for both of these genes here.
So again, this would be normal expression, so that's why there's no variants, normal expression.
APOE 2 is lower risk of, again, both heart disease and Alzheimer's disease.
And this is the APOE 4, so you can either have one APOE 4 allele, or you can have two.
So obviously, if you have two, that's the highest risk.
So you can take a look at your genetic report and kind of determine what your status is, and then things that we can do to help reduce the risk if you do have APOE 4 status, which really just means those lipids are not being transported as well as they should throughout the body to have that protective measure in your brain, and in the cardiovascular system.
So here are some supplements that you can take to support APOE 4 risk status.
So curcumin, it's really anti-inflammatory throughout the entire body, but we know that curcumin does cross the blood brain barriers, so it has wonderful anti-inflammatory properties that really help minimize inflammation within the brain.
So this is a great supplement. We use something called curcuclear here, that's the name of our curcumin supplement, but you can just type in if you're on our web store, you can type in any of these names here, and you can find products that contain those ingredients.
Whooprazine A is another ingredient that supports memory, lots of studies are showing that it supports memory, but Copa is an herb that supports the nervous system and helps to ensure neural transmitter balance.
Incobaloba has cognitive support properties, neural protective properties, vinpocetine is also neural protective.
Omega-3 is our anti-inflammatory fats, and so you can eat foods that are high in omega-3s, so olive oil, you know olives, nuts and seeds are have omega-3 properties,
so you can consume those in your diet, or you can take an omega-3 supplement to just really flood the system with those healthy anti-inflammatory fats, and if you do have FADS variants, then omega-3s are even more important.
So there's a number of different genes that kind of piggyback off of each other, and if you have variants in multiple genes kind of with, you know, that have the same components or touching on different parts of the same things like FADS, then you can have compounding effects.
So if you have APOE4 status, and you have FADS variants, then it's even more important to supplement or make sure you're getting healthy amounts of omega-3s.
Phosphatital colon is another important nutrient essential for memory, brain health also important in maintaining the integrity of that cell membrane, and then there's a gene that is associated with colon production that's the PEMT gene, so if you have variants in the PEMT gene, and in the APOE gene, phosphatital colon is going to be really important for you.
Luteolin reduces neural inflammation, so all of these are things that you can look into and use to support as supplements to help reduce your risk if you do have that APOE4 variant.
And then lifestyle factors are also really important because as we mentioned earlier, your genes are not your destiny, so just knowing where you have some of these variants can really be a game changer, so you know where to focus your energy, you know what you really need to do to reduce your risk.
The risk exercise is just number one way to help overall with health and with APOE4 risk status, so healthy exercise, healthy diet as well, so diets high in healthy fats, low on refined carbohydrates are the best for APOE risk status, avoiding alcohol really important.
So in coconut oil, that's a great fat, it is a saturated fat, but it is a healthy one and it's great for brain health, focusing on lowering your toxic load and supporting the liver, so we want to make sure that we are minimizing our exposures to toxins as much as possible because we know that toxins.
So they can cross the blood brain barrier and toxins are what can create inflammation within the brain, toxins can lodge themselves into the arteries and kind of get into that space between the lumen of the artery and the artery wall and those toxins are what then trigger the plaque build up in the arteries, the plaque is really protective in the arteries and it's also protective in the brain.
It's there to try and protect the brain and the arteries from those toxins that get in there, but what happens then is the top or the plaque build up is disrupting the function of the brain, you know, impeding neurotransmitters, impeding those synapses.
So and then in the arteries, you know, it's creating that, you know, thickening of the wall, so the constriction of the artery and so it's creating contributing to heart disease. So we want to make sure we are lowering our toxic burden as much as possible, you know, from our food, from our environment, from our household products, the things that we're using on our skin and, you know, soaps and hair care products, all of those things are important to take a look at.
And then supporting your liver because we need to be able to detox these things where we're never going to be able to be 100% toxin free so there is going to be some exposure and the air that we're breathing food that we're consuming, you know, things that we're doing.
So we want to make sure we have proper detoxification so I'm important to look at the detox pathways with your genetics and do things to support making sure we're detoxing appropriately and maintaining liver health.
So of course, Dr. Connors has the detoxification course. So if you're interested in supporting your liver and your detoxification, take a look at that course as well.
And then quality sleep is really important when we are sleeping. It's really the time when the brain really kind of detoxes itself.
You know, when we're awake and we're performing so many functions throughout the day, your brain isn't really able to do a lot of that detoxing so sleep kind of creates the scenario where your brain actually kind of shrinks a little bit.
And the fluid that is kind of going through all of those nicks and crannies and spaces in the brain is really kind of washing through collecting all the toxins and then your body is getting rid of those. So sleep is really important for brain health and getting rid of toxins and, you know, reducing risk for Alzheimer's disease and then just really for mood and any behavioral issues.
mood issues as well. So hopefully this gives you a little more insight into the APOE gene again. If you do have APOE for status, you know, try to implement some of these things and know that, you know, you're not destined for for Alzheimer's disease or heart disease or so many things that you can do.
And just knowing your status is the first step so you can focus on these strategies and prevent these things from happening. All right. Thank you for listening. Bye bye.